I think most of us have seen games like this: it’s
turn five or so, and a player is getting ready to
go to attacks. Immediately, a chorus erupts from
the would-be attacker’s opponents. “C’mon man,
I don’t have anything!” “Hey don’t attack
me, I missed a land drop.” “Really,
you’re gonna attack me, my deck is just trying
to be funny.” I like to call this style of table
engagement SBS—“Smol Bean Syndrome”—when a player
goes out of their way to paint their deck as being
in a bad spot and deserving of nothing but mercy.
Now, commander’s nature as a multiplayer format
means that table politics naturally play a
major role in a lot of games. In addition,
a lot of people play EDH specifically for a less
cutthroat MTG experience—not everybody at every
table is trying to win quickly, or even win at
all. I’m not a big fan of most forms of Smol Bean
Syndrome due to their tendency to discourage
attacks and artificially lengthen games,
but I can accept that not everybody is
trying to play the same kind of EDH I am.
However, there are also people who share my
desire to play quicker and more cutthroat games,
and who employ Smol Bean Syndrome more
tactically. This may be intentional,
but it also might not be, which brings me
to a major reason for SBS’s existence—deck
inconsistency. If somebody has an
inconsistent deck, one with some
powerful and/or explosive cards but a lack of
support or connective tissue for such cards,
there will naturally be moments of popping off and
moments of the opposite of popping off. This means
that such a player can be telling the truth
when they say they’re having a whiff moment,
but this can still be a deception in some sense
of the word. Let’s try an exercise real quick.
Here’s a graph of their deck’s performance,
with the Y-axis being power and the X-axis
being percentile of power at a given moment,
you know 20% of the time they’ll be at least
this level of powerful, 80% of the time they’ll
be at least this much lower quantity of powerful.
Make sense? No? Great. You’ve obviously got
this moderately small percentage of the time
where their deck is absolutely going ham,
doing whatever it is that powerful decks do,
but also this gulf back here where their deck is
farting around doing nothing. Certainly, they’re
having a bad time here. But this is often a
situation arising from deckbuilding choices—a deck
that dedicates too much space to the synergistic
and the explosive will have some big turns and
occasionally massive wins, but also a lot of
moments where it withers to a single removal
spell, or just can’t quite put the pieces of the
puzzle together. These moments could be made less
frequent by running more of that connective
tissue—more filtering, more small-scale draw,
and more small creatures and low-cost interaction
cards to protect themself. If they’re ramping
to big cards, they could run a larger proportion
of small-scale ramp spells in their deck so they
successfully ramp to where they want to be more
than 40% of the time. When a person is piloting a
sort of all-or-nothing deck, Smol Bean Syndrome is
a form of power-level smoothing, a way of papering
over the power crater they made for themselves and
bolstering these weakest moments. And I don’t mean
this as an attack necessarily—if this sounds like
you, please, take this as deck building advice.
A related concept to Smol Bean Syndrome is people
who don’t verbally talk down their game state,
but who do play in a way that conceals how
well they’re doing. Now, at a cEDH table,
this is the norm, and as it should be at that
power. You’re trying to win a cutthroat game of
magic against other people trying to win even more
cutthroatedly, and you have every right to bluff,
to downplay your game state, and to otherwise
engage in low-level deception. At a more
middling power level though, this might not
be the best way to go. If you’re playing a
deck with a clear wincon, people know what to
expect even if they’re a bit scared about it,
but if you’re playing a deck whose wins
result from weird tech pieces interacting
to create unexpected avalanches of value
and boardstate—well, people might get a
bit apprehensive. When a deck is doing a
lot of things but it’s unclear how it wins,
people may be asking themselves the question
“oh god, is it that? Or is it that?”
Additionally, there are some strategic ways of
playing that might involve saving resources, and
trying to force other people to use interaction
first. You might say to yourself, “hmm that card
is spooky, but if I bluff no removal somebody
else might deal with it and they’ll have less
removal when I wanna do something spooky later.”
My friend Mr. Hans calls this “playing like a
nerd,” and though it’s decent from a strategic
standpoint, it’s the kind of slightly-ratty
playstyle that people will eventually catch onto.
Whether or not you get punished for playing shady
or playing nerdy will depend on the table, but
you should keep in mind that human beings have
a natural tendency to fear the unknown, even if
being unknown might feel like the correct play.
For an example of a deck that performs almost the
opposite way, let’s talk about my Glissa deck—I
talk about it a lot, and I will do so again here.
That deck consists of ramp, draw spells, removal,
and big creatures. No bursty wins, no surprises,
and no weird tech pieces or out of place synergy
cards hogging space. There’s nothing spicy
with the commander either—she just adds draw
to improve consistency and is a good blocker to
help with survivability. The deck simply does its
battlecruiser thing—people who’ve played against
the deck know that’s what it does, and if people
ask me what it does that’s what I’ll tell them.
If I’m currently behind while playing that deck,
well guess what, when I get back on my feet
you can expect more ramp, draw, big creatures,
and removal. Get ready. It’s a very consistent
deck, and it’s also what I’ll call a transparent
deck. By this I mean, you can always approximate
how well it’s doing by looking at the boardstate,
cards in hand, and land count of the
deck. If the deck has a big board,
well the threat is right there, no extreme
synergies or combos to worry about later.
If the deck has a lot of cards in hand, there’s a
good chance it’s packing a lot of removal. If the
deck has a big land count, there are all sorts of
moderately scary things you need to worry about,
but the odds of the spookiest outcomes are
lessened the fewer cards in hand the deck
has. It’s a powerful deck against a lot of
conventionally built mid-power decks—I call
it Midrange-Crusher 5000 for a reason—but
the transparency and absence of sudden
wincons means that people tend to worry
about it less than they probably should.
Another transparent deck I have is my Meria
deck, and though that one has more unique tech
and response plays, it’s transparent because
it’s a Voltron deck—the problem is right there
on the board in front of you. If there’s
a Meria on board with a lot of equipments,
I’m doing pretty well. Most of my draws will be
exiles off the top, so you’re seeing most of the
stuff I’m seeing—the scary stuff is all visible.
There might be some protection spells in my hand,
but the deck devotes a full 10% of its space to
protection, so that much shouldn’t be a shock.
Meria also has the advantage over Glissa that
it’s low-to-the-ground—my deck can create a value
engine with its commander to exile cards, but
that value is more small artifacts and creatures,
and the deck doesn’t do much if the artifact
count is low or the commander gets removed.
Even with a high artifact count, the deck still
only hits one player a turn and gains maybe
four cards worth of value. My $25 Rakdos
discard deck is even lower to the ground,
only incrementally drawing cards
with a handful of scrappy creatures,
and honestly that’s the deck’s only saving grace.
It deletes people’s hands and makes them upset,
but the rest of the deck is just grindy creatures
and a commander to clear the way for my small
group of 2/2s and 3/3s to attack. People will
sometimes attack it out of spite for a bit,
but the non-discard portion of the deck
is so utterly fair-magic that people will
usually go “oh, you’re just doing that now.
Huh.” And won’t worry about it too much.
All three of these decks pair well with a
style of table engagement I like to call
fight-the-table ideology—they can happily admit
to exactly what they plan to do, they can do it
fairly consistently, and they are prepared for
the consequences if they become an enemy. Me and
Mr. Hans originally coined this phrase to describe
the optimal playstyle for mixed power level games,
or alternatively games where one player gets
a decisive advantage early. If you’re playing
more powerfully than other people, you could
play close to the chest before popping off
with a power-turn and deleting the table, but
that’s not really fun for anybody. However,
give your opponents the information they need to
know and be open about the general shape of what
your deck is doing, specifically how it wins
and what cards you’re playing are doing there,
and suddenly you’ve got a dynamic game
where your opponents are strategizing
about how to keep you in check while
managing their own individual plans.
Any deck can partake in this ideology in
a game playing against lower power decks,
and I encourage giving it a try, but as
a method it also works as a more general
style of deckbuilding and play. Now, I can
already hear some of you say “but Alex,
why would I want to be the enemy? I don’t
want my life total to be yeeted into the
sun by a bunch of quivering nerds who I’ve been
smugly informing of their impending demise at
the hands of my deck.” Well first, if you are
in a dominant position, doing literally that
can lead to some really fun gameplay as long as
you’re not an ass about it. But more broadly,
this method can actually save your deck
from some hate, and let’s talk about that.
This might seem odd for hate-dodging, but step
one of fight-the-table ideology is that you should
pose some sort of clear threat to the table with
a good degree of consistency. This could be early
damage, big midgame beats, boardwipes, stax, and
so forth. This will mostly come down to building
a deck that’s focused and isn’t filled with
unnecessary tech pieces or creatures out of
sync with the gameplan, and you can accomplish
this step on a shockingly low budget. The point
of this step is that what you’re doing needs
to be visible. To go back to an earlier point,
I’ve seen hyper-techy midrange decks which fill
their board with unusual permanents with no clear
sense of how they’ll be used. If you do this,
people might feel a looming sense of threat,
but with no obvious sense of what to worry about
this might simply result in them attacking you. By
contrast, if the threat is visible, people
can make their own educated calculations,
and that calculation might just be “eh,
it’ll probably be fine.” Similarly,
consistency is important because that will be
baked into people’s calculations as well. If
we take the inconsistent, explosive deck I was
talking about earlier and average out the power,
it might very well be lower than a deck engaging
in fight-the-table ideology. But people aren’t
gonna be thinking about averages, they’re gonna be
thinking about the fact that you swung for 90 at
them on turn 5 last game, and that’s a lot scarier
than a deck that consistently swings for 15.
Step two of fight-the-table ideology is to be open
about the threat your deck poses to the table.
This doesn’t mean you need to overhype yourself
or give people constant updates on your draws,
but be straightforward with people. Verbally, this
could mean saying, “yeah my deck generates a lot
of artifact tokens, which I can use to accomplish
various effects. I don’t have very many right now,
so I’ll need to get a lot more and have an
outlet for them before I can do anything too
scary.” In terms of play, being open can
just mean having a thing you’re clearly
doing. Don’t let your opponents imagine what
you’re doing with all these fishy plays,
have a goal and execute clear steps along the way.
One easy example for this is hardcore ramp decks,
which work well because everybody knows they’re
scary at a lot of mana, but there’s no singular
land drop that signals the deck being a problem.
It evokes more of a gentle gradient of concern
from your opponents rather than the black and
white concern of a random spooky permanent,
and this can lead to the deck flying under
the radar. This is doubly true if you’re not
running a singular win card like Torment of
Hailfire, but rather a win involving multiple
cards used in a complex way, since that
can kinda just blend together in people's
minds as “yeah the deck does big things when it
gets a lot of mana,” which is conceptually less
scary than a one shot. This sort of ramp
deck is a great example of transparency
being unexpectedly effective at avoiding
attacks compared to more opaque playstyles.
I’ve laid out the basic framework, but
a natural question that might arise is,
“can my deck be played this way?” I do my best
to play decks that are relatively consistent,
so a lot of mine do end up following this mold,
but even in my case some decks will be trickier
to do this with than others. Decks with combos
are generally more difficult to do this with,
as they’re naturally less transparent due to the
level of importance they place on cards in hand,
which is by definition a hidden zone. For this
reason and others, sometimes a deck isn’t a
great candidate for this kind of transparency
treatment. However, I think that a good exercise
for every deck is thinking about what it would
have to do to become a good candidate for this.
What happens if you remind your opponents of
the strongest wincon of your deck, along with
the conditions required to get there, right at
the start of every game? What happens if your
opponents treat that wincon you mention seriously?
If your deck is sometimes a slow midrange deck and
other times an explosive combo list, well, that
might be something to interrogate a bit more.
I have a couple of other things to say about
“playing like a nerd” and other forms of
pseudo-politics, but I couldn’t find a nice
place to fit them into this video. Instead,
I posted them in a three minute long unlisted
video. I’ve left a link in the description to
that video and it’ll probably stay there for a
little while, but at some point I’m gonna edit
it out. You’ll be able to find that link on my
patreon after that, and there will likely be more
endnotes like that posted there in the future,
along with occasional full-length bonus videos.
Sign up at patreon.com/SalubriousSnail for $3
a month if more content sounds up your alley.